hi in this module i'm going to be
talking about markov network
so far we've introduced constraint
satisfaction problems the first of our
variable based models now we're going to
talk about markov networks the second
type of variable based models which will
connect factor graphs with probability
and this will be a stepping stone along
the way to network
so recall that variable based models are
all based on factor graphs and markov
networks are no
different so remember that a factor
graph consists of a set of variables x1
n
and a set of factors f1 through fm
where each factor takes a subset of the
variables and returns a negative number
if you multiply all of these numbers
together you can evaluate the weight of
a particular assignment
so let's look at example of object
tracking so here remember the goal is
over
time
record the noisy sensor
reading of
an object position at zero
two and two and the goal is to figure
out what the actual trajectory of this
object
we model this as a factor graph follows
where we have a number of factors
representing uh the affinity for x1 to
be
close to zero f x two to be close to two
and x three close to two and also
adjacent positions to be close to each
other
so
before we treated this factor graph as a
constraint satisfaction problem where
the goal is to find the maximum weight
assignment
and in this particular example we can
look at the all the possible assignments
each assignment has a weight
and
find that the maximum weight assignment
is 1
2
but just returning a single maximum way
assignment
doesn't really give us the full picture
in particular it doesn't represent how
certain we are of
this assignment and what about all the
other possibilities
so the goal of markov networks is to try
to capture this uncertainty over
assignments using the language
probability
so we've actually done most of the hard
work already by setting up vector graphs
the only remaining part is to connect
factor graphs with probability
so formally a markup network or a markov
random field as it's sometimes called is
a factor graph which defines a joint
distribution
over a set of random variables x1
through xn
so before these were just variables and
now their random variables become
talking about probabilities
so remember the factor graph gives us a
weight
for each possible assignment x
and to convert this weight into a
probability we just need to normalize it
so what i mean by that is i'm going to
look at
the sum over all possible weights
all possible assignments and their
weights
and i'm going to define z
as the sum of all the weights and that's
going to be called the normalization
constant or sometimes called the
partition function
and then i'm just going to divide by z
so this is going to produce
something that sums to 1
and i'm going to define that as a joint
distribution over big x
equals the assignment little x
okay so let's do this example here we
have um
uh x1 x2 x3 and the weight of x so for
this uh we have a bunch of eight
possible or not um or six possible
non-zero weight assignments with
particular weights
we add all these weights up that gives
us the partition function z which is
26 here and then we divide each of these
weights by 26 to produce joint
probability
and so now this probability distribution
represents the uncertainty in the
problem
and notice that while one two two was
the maximum weight assignment and it
still is
this probability gives us a more nuanced
picture which is that we're only 31
percent sure that that is actually the
true uh trajectory that object so this
could be useful information there's a
big difference between 31 and 90
but wait we can do more than that so the
language of probability as can allow us
to ask for other answer other questions
besides just probabilities of all
assignments
for example if we wanted to know what
was
where was object at time step 2
so that is what is the value f of random
variable x2 and i don't care about x1
and x3
so this query is captured by a quantity
called marginal probability
and the marginal probability of a
particular random variable
equaling a particular value v is given
by
so we write this as p of x i equals v
and this is given by just summing over
all possible
full assignments such that x i equals v
so all assignments conditio
consistent with this condition
of the joint distribution which we
defined on the previous slide
so now let's look at this object
tracking example again
so we
have our joint probability table that we
computed on the previous slide and now
let's compute some probabilities of
marginal probability so first let's
consider what is the probability of x2
equals one here
so to do that we look over here and look
at all the rows where x2 was one so
that's this first four here
and then we just add up their
probabilities so that's 0.15 0.15 0.15.5
and that gives us 0.6
and now we can issue another
marginal probability query what's the
probability of x2 equals 2
and look at all the rows where x2 is 2
and these are these last two rows
and we add up these probabilities and
that gives us a point
there's some rounding error here
why this doesn't add up exactly
okay so that allows us to answer
marginal probability
so one thing you might note is that
the answer here is actually different
than what if you just look at the max
weight assignment
in particular if you look at the maximum
weight assignment it says the most
likely thing is that x2
is one two two and you look at x2 oh and
it says two
but notice that that is not the most
likely
marg under the marginal probability the
most likely uh value for x2 under
marginal probability is one and it has
62 percent chance of being a one in that
case
so
the intuition here is that while this
trajectory
is has indeed the largest weight
um there is actually a lot of
decentralized evidence for x2 equals one
with these assignments which have less
weight but kind of strengthen numbers we
if you add up all these weights they
actually out
number um the evidence for x2 equals
so this is kind of an important lesson
that
what question
what answer you're going to get really
depends on the type of question you're
asking
and in this case if you're really
interested in objects at time step 2
then marginal probability is
so let's look at a particular example so
the easy model is a very canonical
example that dates back to the 1920s
from statistical physics
and the idea was that this is a model of
ferromagnetism
so the idea is that you have um a markup
network which contains a bunch of
different sites um
and each site is going to be denoted x i
which can take on two values minus one
and plus one so minus one represents a
down spin and plus one represents um an
up spin
and furthermore
all these uh
variables are going to be related by
a factor so we're going to call this f
i j
which connects the site i and site j
it's going to depend on the spin of i
and the spin of type j
and that's going to be equal to
um
x of
beta times x i x j
okay so the intuition is that we want
neighboring insights to have the same
okay so by multiplying these together
uh if both of them are have the same
sign then this is going to be one if
they have opposite signs they're going
to be negative one
and beta here is a scaling that says how
strong is the
affinity so if theta is zero
that means uh this is just x of zero
which is one so that means there's no
connection between and as beta increases
then the affinity becomes stronger the
difference between
them a green and not a green becomes
heightened
so one thing uh easy models are useful
for is to study phase transitions in the
ethical systems so here is an example of
what happens when a beta increases
so
this
if beta is close to zero then you're
basically going to get unstructured
systems where
each site is just behaving independently
in fact if beta is zero then you all
assignments are equally likely
and as beta increases you'll see that
more and more coherence happens
where neighboring sites really like to
be close to each other but of course
there's going to be some kind of sharp
ridges where um two neighbors have to
disagree
so how we're gonna sample from
this model
is going to be a topic for another
module
so here is another canonical application
of markov networks from computer vision
so this used to be very popular before
um so the idea is that you take a noisy
image and you want to denoise it into a
clean image
so we're going to present a very
stylized uh simple example of this
so here is our
three by five image so each side is a
pixel and we assume that
we only
so x i is either zero or one
uh which is a pixel value which is
unknown we're modeling the clean image
and we assume that only a subset of the
pixels are observed so maybe we observe
this one this one this one this one
this one and the uh the goal is to fill
in the rest of the pixels
so we can capture
this observation
by an observation potential of o i x i
which is one if x i agrees with the
observation and zero if it doesn't so
this is a hard constraint that says
where i observed a value
x i must take on that value so this one
has to be zero this one has to be one
and so on
and finally we have um
transition factors that say neighboring
pixels are more likely to be the same
than different so again the same
intuition is the easy model
and we're going to denote this as tij
and this equals
is 2 if two
neighboring pixels agree
and is going to be one if they
so
let me summarize markov networks you can
think about it succinctly as taking
factor graphs and
marrying them with probability
so again factor graphs already have done
a lot of the work they allow already you
to specify a non-negative weight for
every assignment and all we have to do
is normalize that to get a probability
distribution
and once we have the probability
distribution we can answer all sorts of
queries for example computing marginal
probabilities which allows us to
pinpoint individual variables and ask
questions about them
so it is useful comparing markup
networks with uh csp
so dsps we talked about variables who
are known unknown
and
markov networks it's
we're call them random variables uh
maybe hive behave like variables but
they're random variables because um
we're endowing them with a probabilistic
interpretation
in csps we talked about weights
markov networks we talked about
probabilities which are the normalized
weights
and the main difference is that in csps
we were trying to find the maximum
weight assignment
and in markov networks we're looking at
the distribution over
assignments holistically and answering
questions about marginal probabilities
which gives us a more nuanced idea of
the set of possible
okay that's it for this module